it's when you involve social media
you're also putting yourself out there
for a lot of people they're gonna be
watching out for every little detail
about your relationship
did Alison Rhea go from dating Bryce
Hall to bailing him out of jail even
though her mom says they've broken up
Bryce might have insider info about
Alison status with the hype house how
did the relationship get to this point
and what comes next for this famous pair
of tick tock stars there are plenty of
fans out there who are holding out hope
that maybe Addison Rae and Bryce Hall
didn't really break up but while they do
look cute together a very persuasive
source confirmed the bad news notorious
cool mom Sheri easterly replied to a
fans comment about her daughter and
Bryce looking cute together with they
are not together possible Sheri has a
good reason for not wanting her daughter
associated with Bryce right now on May
20th 2020 Bryce tweeted that the sway
House members were planning to take a
cross-country road trip despite the Cova
19 pandemic but their trip didn't quite
go according to plan since it ended up
with Bryce Hall and Jaden Hustler being
arrested for possession and Giddings
Texas before long both Bryce and Jaden
were free after posting bail but there
are rumors they may have had a little
bit of help
ticker talker reported that Addison was
the one who stepped up to bail Bryce out
of jail we all want to know about the
breakup between Addison and Bryce but
even bigger news is the possibility of
Addison breaking up with hi pals ever
since dick talks Dixie to Amelia left
the creative collective fans have
theorize that Addison may be on her way
out if she isn't gone already and Bryce
definitely added some fuel to those
rumors by discussing the hype house in a
video Charlie but high-pass co-founder
thomas petrov fired back that Bryce
doesn't know anything about their
business and accused him of creating
drama
Thomas Petrova may want Bryce to stop
commenting on hi pals but his friend
seemed to think he needs to stop
crushing on Addison his fellow sway
House member Griffin Johnson made it
tick talked about Bryce accusing him of
having the fattest crush on Addison if
you got the fattest crush on Addison and
you want a minute just keep watching
this I so now that Bryce halls here hey
dude I just woke up you want to you want
to go to gym huh
he posted a similar sentiment on Twitter
a month earlier by tweeting Rice Hall
can't get over his ex was Griffin
calling him out or just trying to rile
him up just because Bryce Madison aren't
dating doesn't mean they aren't on bad
terms
in fact Bryce has been loud and proud
about the fact that Addison is the best
girl he had ever dated he confirmed the
two of them still talk but just as
friends and not romantic partners Bryce
denied rumors and the two had reconciled
but said he's open to the idea of seeing
her again in the future
yes well Bryce admitted he's not sure if
he and Addison will ever be an item he
also clarified that he's happy being
single for now during interview
confirmed
declaring that he is single and loving
it although he has nothing but good
things to say about Addison he missed
that being in a relationship can be
stressful because of their careers they
had to deal with any potential drama
playing out very publicly on social
media and that can be exhausting
according to Bryce Keenan quarantine has
made it a lot harder to create
compelling content maybe that's what
convinced the suede house it was time to
go on a road trip but for a while we
were seeing more home-based
collaborations including a video of
Bryce haw and Josh Richards on Instagram
during the short clip
Bryce declares that he's going to get
back with Addison
opossum
it can be great to get emotional support
from friends after a breakup with Bryce
and his friends are really more about
teasing each other Nick being responded
to his split with Addison by posting
photos of her all over Bryce's room and
of course they had to film it for
YouTube at one point during the video
Bryce clearly referred to Addison as his
ex-girlfriend
even though Bryce is clearly open to
reconciling at some points mini fans
worry it will be too late some people
suspect she's already involved with
youtuber david dobrik the two have been
spending time together and even
collaborated on a tik-tok together my
walk this way and do it we all know the
couple who creates together stays
together and this could explain why so
many fans are shippi nice to but at the
time David denied dating Addison or
anyone else for that matter
the same day David and Addison posted a
cute tik tok together bryce posted one
of his infamously vague he had
intriguing tweets he tweeted a simple
I'm miss yeild
causing everyone to jump to the
conclusion that he was referring to
Addison and is not just his hopeful fans
who think this Bryce tried to say he was
talking about his friends but they were
clearly skeptical that he didn't bother
to type you guys after I miss you during
an interview with Entertainment Tonight
Addison finally opened up about her
relationship with Bryce or lack thereof
she admitted the two of them had love
for one another but denied being in a
serious relationship we're super good
friends I guess for now it's just best
that we stay that way while Addison
didn't dive into details Bryce had
spilled some more tea during an
interview earlier in the month when
Bryce sat down with Holly wire he knew
we all wanted to hear about what was
really going on between him and Addison
according to Bryce the two of them were
talking at this point with their
schedules made it difficult to get a
relationship started we only won on like
one date but it's like we're both super
busy he revealed that their first date
took place at a sushi restaurant and
even though they hadn't had a ton of
one-on-one time
is optimistic about their future
together but it's going well right now
although Bryce seemed confident during
his chat with Holly wire some of his
statements were confusing considering
that he had posted on Twitter just a
couple of days earlier Bryce had tweeted
that he and Addison were not dating and
were doing their own things separately
from one another they were still going
to be hanging out without being kissy
Kissy anymore
these two were definitely top notch when
it came to flirty banter but it seems as
though things may have never gone much
further than the talky stage it's
understandable that fans spent so much
time confused about what was going on
between these two especially since they
love teasing their fans with tic toc
videos suggesting something romantic was
going on between them like the time they
filmed themselves dancing to a song
called relationship then there was his
tick-tock from a couple of days before
where Addison asked Bryce you okay so
maybe she didn't ask so much as lip sync
but hey this is a tick tock we're
talking about of course Bryce indicated
he did find her cute and she snuggled
her head up against him seriously these
two looks so cute it's no wonder fans
couldn't get enough of their will they
won't their relationship in fact January
was full of tick tocks made by these two
that definitely seemed to hint something
was going on there's this one which
jokingly implies Bryce was cheating on
Addison with one of his friends and
another that showed them coming
precariously close to sharing a kiss
looking back they were clearly just
messing with us but who could resist
hoping things were going to work out and
their overly flirtatious behavior wasn't
just limited to their tick-tock accounts
Bryce took to Instagram to post this
cute pic of himself and Addison with the
caption she's cool sometimes we all know
Addison is awesome 24/7 so this might be
the understatement of the century
meanwhile Addison posted a sweet
tick-tock of Bryce trying to keep up
with her dance moves and this was just
one of many cute moments they shared
with their fans around this time period
even though they insisted there was
definitely nothing
going on between them at one point fry
seaman posted a picture of them kissing
right on Instagram for everyone to see
well if they were willing to scroll
through numerous photos of him smooching
his fans first and in the very last
photo on the post is a snap of him and
Addison they could definitely be given
each other a platonic pact or they could
just be positioned in a way that implies
a scandalous smooch was taking place
[Music]
Addison and Bryce didn't only
collaborate with each other they make
plenty of videos with other friends as
well like the time they pair it up with
Chase Hudson and Charlie D Emilio who
were in a romantic relationship with
each other was this just a fun dance
session or signs of a double date
between two couples the same day Bryce
posted a flirtatious video of just
himself and Addison and his personal
tick-tock accounts if you thought Bryce
talked a lot about his maybe
relationship with Addison that's nothing
compared with how much he hyped up his
bromance with his now ex-girlfriend Elle
Dan Jean rice confirmed their
relationship back in January 2019 and
while the two of them had some super
sweet moments they didn't exactly end on
a positive note
at one point Bryce accused Elle of
stealing his phone and accused her of
being a cloud chaser who was not only
using him but Lauren gray as well
Elle fired back that Bryce is no angel
before they officially ended things in
july 2019 just a few months after his
breakup from Elle Bryce met Addison
when she started visiting that way and
the rest is history what do you think
about Bryce hall and Addison Rae where
they really together or was their
relationship more friendly than romantic
the whole time do you think they'll get
back together let us know what you think
in the comment section and don't forget
to click subscribe and turn on your
notifications for more great videos from
us here at the things bye for now
you